Speaker 1: All right, a big story breaking this
morning about the January 6th investigation,
it happens to be really bad news for the Trump
family. Eric Trump as well as Kimberly Guilfoyle
phone records have been subpoenaed and reportedly
obtained by the Jan. six committee, again pushing
forward into the inner circle around Trump and
theoretically, eventually to Trump himself. Eric
Trump is one of Trump's sons. Kimberly Guilfoyle
is the fiancee of Don Jr., and their records now
are becoming part of the investigation. CNN
reporting exclusive Eric Trump and Kimberly
Guilfoyle phone records subpoenaed by the January
six committee. The House Committee investigating
the Jan. six attack on the Capitol, has subpoenaed
and obtained records of phone numbers associated
with one of former Trump's children, Eric Trump,
as well as Kimberly Guilfoyle. It appears to be
the first time the select committee has issued
a subpoena that targeted a member of the Trump
family and what marks a significant escalation
of the investigation into Trump's role in the
January 6th insurrection. The decision to subpoena
communication records involving the Trump family
underscores the aggressive tack the committee is
taking as it races to complete its investigation
while battling Trump in court over access to
documents. The phone records obtained by the
committee are part of a new round of call detail
records. These records provide the committee with
logs that show incoming and outgoing calls,
including date, time and length of calls.
The records show a log of text messages,
but not necessarily the substance or
content. This is fascinating because this
is this is that the so-called metadata
and one of the things that we learned from Edward
Snowden's exposures are about practices of bulk
metadata collection and one of the things
that the right has been very quick to say
some on the right who want to defend government
surveillance. Not it, not all of them do. The
libertarian minded ones don't, but sometimes they
say, Listen, this is just metadata. After all,
it's not actually the substance and the kind.
It's not recordings of calls or the text of text
messages. Well, that's what's here. That's what
we're talking about here. And they are flipping
out because they have done this with regard to
Eric Trump and Kimberly Guilfoyle. Both Eric Trump
and Guilfoyle played prominent roles in Trump's
Stop the Steal efforts, including Guilt Guilfoyle
fundraising off of the lie that the election was
stolen. They both spoke on the Jan. six rally that
led to the attack on the Capitol. The records
may help the committee flesh out text messages
and phone records from others like Mark Meadows,
fundraisers and rally organizers. CNN reported
last month that the committee already subpoenaed
phone records of more than 100 different people.
The newly obtained records include the cell
phone number used by Eric Trump. The cell phone
number for Guilfoyle was confirmed by sources
familiar with her number and texts. The committee
previously identified the number as Guilfoyle, so
they already knew that there was no indication the
committee has directly subpoenaed either Eric
Trump or Guilfoyle for interviews or documents.
Nor is there any evidence that the committee
subpoenaed records related to Trump's other
kids Ivanka Don Jr. or son in law Jared Kushner.
Now Ivanka and Junior and Jared. They can't really
be far behind. Is my instinct on this and Trump's
relationship, you know, the same way that Trump
doesn't seem to understand, like how to relate to
dogs, to pets, it's just this weird kind of thing.
There's a similar thing with Trump's kids that
we've noticed. I'm not even sure that Trump would
be that upset if his kids went to prison to save
his ass. I think he would be sort of embarrassed
because of how it would look. But it doesn't
really seem he would care that much. And as far
as the timing of the investigation understand,
as I said earlier in thinking about 2022,
this committee ends. If Democrats lose the
House in November made effective in January,
when the new House gets sworn in. So
at the current pace, the idea would be
they are done before the midterms. I, you
know, when we talk about an October surprise,
it's completely plausible that the investigation
will be done before the midterms and that there
would be some major report with takeaways and
it would be an October surprise. I just have a
hard time imagining that it would affect the
elections. I don't think whatever comes out of
this is going to change anybody's minds because
if the committee determines Trump was responsible
and here's all the people that Coke, you
know, coke inspired, that's already what
we intuitively believe based on everything
we know so far and everything that's public
and the Republicans don't care, they would reelect
him like that. Most of them would anyway. So on
the one hand, the timing of the election makes
it important for this to be completed in time.
At the same time, it's hard to imagine anything
that comes out of this that actually affects the
midterms. If you disagree with me, if you think
there's something that could actually affect the
midterms and change people's minds, who would
otherwise vote for these Trumpian Republicans?
Let me know. And the sort of last piece of
this is imagine that the January 6th Committee
finds evidence of criminality and turns it over to
the to the to the Department of Justice. It would
take months at minimum after the release
of the report for the DOJ to investigate
and then to charge anybody. So the timing of
that also would not end up affecting the 2022
midterms. So on the one hand, this is incredibly
important work that must be done, and I want it
to be completed in a reasonable amount of time.
On the other hand, it's more for the historical
record, quite frankly, and maybe for its use
in 2024, if Trump does run again than it is
for affecting the 2022 midterms. If you disagree
and if you believe there is a way that this report
would actually influence the midterms, let me
know. You can email info at David Pakman dot com